We're asked to find the
product 2x plus 8
times 2x minus 8.
So there's two ways to do it.
We can just multiply it out like
we've always done, but
this is actually a
special pattern.
This is a special pattern, where
we have an a plus a b,
where a in this case
is 2x and b is 8.
And we have that being
multiplied by a minus b,
where, once again, a is 2x
and b is equal to 8.
Whenever you have this pattern,
it simplifies to a
squared minus b squared.
And I'll show you at the end
of this video why it is.
But we can just do
this pattern.
We have a plus b times a minus
b, 2x plus 8 times 2x minus 8.
So this will simplify based on
this pattern right here to a
squared, which is 2x
squared, minus b
squared, minus 8 squared.
So what does this get us?
This gets us 2 squared is 4
times x squared minus 8
squared, minus 64.
And we're done!
Now let's prove to ourselves
that this actually works.
Let's multiply a plus
b times a minus b.
So if we take a plus b times
a minus b, we can first
distribute this.
We can distribute the a plus b
onto each of these terms. So
it'll be this whole purple a
plus b times that a and then
the whole purple a plus b
times that negative b.
So you can view it as
a times a plus b.
And then you can have minus
b times a plus b.
All I did is I distributed
this onto each of those.
That times that, that's right
there, plus that times that,
that's right there.
And then we can distribute
again. a times a is a squared,
a times b is ab, Negative b
times a is negative ab or
negative ba, same thing.
Negative b times b is
negative b squared.
And then you see you have a
positive ab and a negative ab,
they cancel out and
you're left with a
squared minus b squared.
So we could have actually done
this little exercise with 2x
plus 8 and 2x minus 8 and we
would have gotten this.
But it's neater just to see
the general pattern.
Any time you have a plus b times
a minus b, it's going to
be a squared minus b squared.
In this case, a is 2x, so a
squared is 4x squared, b is 8,
so b squared is 64.